FEW ALL OF US SUFFER.
MEANWHILE, THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
BECOME MORE POWERFUL.
THAT'S THE SCARIEST PART AND
MAYBE THE WHOLE POINT.
AUTHOR MARK STEYN JOINS US TO
BREAK DOWN WHAT IS GOING ON.
AT SOME POINT DO YOU THINK THE
CONVERSATION BECOMES WHY WOULD
SOMEONE WANT TO KILL STRANGERS?
WHY ARE AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WANTING TO KILL
STRANGERS?
WHY ARE WE HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION?
>> BECAUSE I THINK THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT -- NOT ONLY CANADA
BUT THE ENTIRE WESTERN WORLD
DON'T WANTED A
DON'T WANTED
DON'T WANT T
DON'T WANT TO
DON'T WANT TO A
DON'T WANT TO ADM
DON'T WANT TO ADMIT
DON'T WANT TO ADMIT T
DON'T WANT TO ADMIT THA
DON'T WANT TO ADMIT THAT
DON'T WANT TO ADMIT THAT T
DON'T WANT TO ADMIT THAT THE
DON'T WANT TO ADMIT THAT THEY
DON'T WANT TO ADMIT THAT THEY N
DON'T WANT TO ADMIT THAT THEY NO
LONGER HAVE CONTROL OF THE
SITUATION.
THIS PART OF TORONTO, WHICH
HAPPENS TO BE MY HOMETOWN, I WAS
HERE A COUPLE WEEKS AGO FOR A
BAR MITZVAH, ALL THE STREETS
HAVE ENGLISH NAMES.
THE SCHOOL IS NAMED AFTER FIELD
MARSHALL LORD HAGUE THAT
COMMANDED BRITISH FORCES.
THEY HAVE STREETS CALLED
PRINCESS AND EMPRESS.
THERE'S ONE NAMED AFTER LORD
BING.
YOU CAN'T FIND ANYBODY WITH
NAMES LIKE THAT IN THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD NOW.
IT'S LARGELY CHINESE, KOREAN.
THERE'S SOME IRANIANS, MOROCCAN,
JEWS.
IN THIS CASE, SOMETHING WITH AN
ARMENIAN NAME.
IF YOU LOOK AT SOCIETY AS LIKE
ONE BIG STAMP COLLECTION AND
IT'S NICE TO HAVE ONE OF
EVERYTHING, THEN THE MODERN
WESTERN CITY IS A GREAT PLACE.
BUT IN THESE MULTICULTURAL HOT
POTS, GRIEVANCES DEVELOP
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER IT'S A
GLOBAL PHENOMENON LIKE JIHAD OR
JUST PECULIAR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
THEN YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
THE JIHAD GUYS HAVE GOT A LOT OF
MILEAGE OUT OF TAKING TRUCKS,
DRIVING THEM UP ON THE
SIDEWALKS, KILLING LARGE NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE.
YOU CAN'T REASONABLY EXPECT THAT
JUST TO BE CONFINED TO MUSLIM
JIHADISTS.
SOONER OR LATER SOME GUY LIKE
THIS WITH AN ARMENIAN NAME AND
ARMENIANS ARE 99.9% CHRISTIAN.
LAST TIME I WAS THERE, THERE
WERE 600 MUSLIMS IN THE WHOLE
JOINT.
BUT YOU CAN'T EXPECT -- WHEN
PEOPLE SEE A CAR CAN KILL LARGE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE, YOU CAN'T
EXPECT PEOPLE TO SAY OH, YEAH,
THAT'S JUST A MUSLIM WEAPON.
THAT'S FOR THE JIHAD.
SO EVENTUALLY OTHER PEOPLE START
RENTING CARS AND DRIVING THEM UP
ON SIDEWALKS.
>> Tucker: IF YOU WERE RUNNING A
SOCIETY, WOULDN'T -- AN
BENEFITTING FROM IT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AS OUR
LEADERS DO, WOULDN'T YOU SPEND
TIME THINKING ABOUT HOLDING IT
TOGETHER?
WHAT MAKES A SOCIETY THAT WILL
WAGE A WAR ON ITS OWN BEHALF
WITH A FOREIGN ADVERSARY?
WHY WOULDN'T YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT?
NOBODY THINKS ABOUT IT AT ALL.
>> NO.
THEY THINK IN HOP IT IS TERMS.
IN CANADA PARTICULARLY LAST
YEAR, FOR THE DOMINION OF CANADA
IS 150th BIRTHDAY, JUSTIN
TRUDEAU CELEBRATED IT BY
AWARDING $10 MILLION TO A
JIHADIST HE HAD HAD SPRING FROM
GITMO WHO KILLED AN AMERICAN
OVER IN AFGHANISTAN.
IN OTHER WORDS, MULTICULTURALISM
LETS YOU DECIDE WHICH SIDE OF
THE WALL YOU WANT TO BE ON,
WHETHER YOU WANTS TO BE ON THE
HOME TEAM OR THE AWAY TEAM.
THAT'S HOW GOOD MULTICULTURALISM
IS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW THEY USE
THESE INCIDENTS TO TAKE AWAY OUR
RIGHTS.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> IN SOME SENSE, TUCKER, IT'S
MORE BASIC THAN THAT EVEN.
I MEAN, SETTING THE RIGHTS TO
ONE SIDE, I NOTICE NOW WHEN
YOU'RE IN LONDON, WHEN YOU'RE IN
BERLIN, WHEN YOU'RE IN BRUSSELS,
WHEN YOU'RE IN PARIS, NOW
PRESUMABLY WHEN YOU'RE IN
TORONTO, THEY'RE TRYING TO PUT
BALLARDS OVER EVERY STRIP OF
RAISED PAVEMENTS SO CARS CAN'T
GET ON THE SIDEWALK TO KILL
PEOPLE.
SO THE PRICE WE PAY IN EFFECT
THE NATIONAL BORDER IS WE NOW
HAVE AN UGLY UP ALL OF OUR
CITIES AND HAVE BALLARDS AROUND
EVERYTHING IN SITE.
ON THE NEW YORK BIKE PATH, FOR
EXAMPLE.
EVERYWHERE YOU GO AROUND ANY
WESTERN CITY, THEY'RE LOOKING
UGLIER AND UGLIER BECAUSE OUR
LEADERS HAVE IN A SENSE
ESTABLISHED UGLINESS AS THE
ORGANIZING PRINCIPLE OF THE
MULTICULTURALISM IN THE 21st
CENTURY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU PUT
LEADERS THINK ABOUT WHO IT MEANS
TO HAVE A HAPPY COHESIVE
SOCIETY.
>> I'D LIKE US TO SOFTEN THE
TARGET.
THAT THINKS ABOUT A BIGGER